petit journal patrick martin géniez
bonjour merci jeu sur notre antenne vous
êtes professeur à sciences po
spécialiste des questions européennes
vous comprenez la fin de non-recevoir de
l'otan aux multiples demandes de zone
d'exclusion aérienne de la patte de
l'ukraine oui je la comprends d'une
certaine façon parce que cette zone
d'exclusion aérienne où aucun avion
russe finalement ne pourraient circuler
nenê aucun autre avion nécessiterait en
effet un apport logistiques militaires
aériens de la part des pays de l'otan et
en effet vladimir poutine a été très
clair ici un avion rendre ce sera
considéré comme une agression militaire
dès lors une agression de l'otan
l'implication de l'otan les pays de
l'otan deviendrait co belligérants
participant directement à ce conflit et
de leurs cela pourrait générer dans une
sorte de conflit d'abord entre les
grandes puissances et puis un conflit
mondial ce que veut absolument éviter
l'otan est ce qu a dit dès le début du
bail de la difficulté ce boulet c'est de
savoir jusqu'à quand l'otan va pouvoir
rester en dehors du conflit
c'est toute la difficulté car vous avez
que vladimir poutine est en train de
dire finalement que même les sanctions
et aux économiques sont considérées
comme un acte de guerre pourrait être
considérée comme un acte de guerre et on
vient d'apprendre ce matin que la
pologne envisageait d'envoyer des avions
mig 29 en ukraine même s'ils ne seraient
pas des pilotes polonais donc on voit
bien qu'il ya une montée de l' escalade
la question de savoir si poutine ne
recherche pas un prétexte pour dire que
le temps est complètement engagés dans
ce conflit les sanctions européennes
jusqu'où selon vous elles peuvent aller
mais elles doivent aller très loin si on
reste sur les sanctions économiques et
financières
il faut véritablement étouffer
l'économie russe qui tu m'aimes
malheureusement à ce que le peuple russe
qui est soumis à une propagande et à
lavage de cerveau en souffrent les
oligarques du régime les proches de
vladimir poutine doivent souffrir on
voit bien effectivement que les systèmes
de paiements internationaux
l'utilisation des cartes bancaires
devient quasiment impossible il ya des
files d'attentes devant les
distributeurs de billets et les
oligarques qui ont accumulé une fortune
considérable depuis 30 ans avec des
yachts et des fortunes fortunes
immobilières vont en souffrir donc il
faut aller le plus loin possible dans
les sanctions économiques de façon à ce
que cela ait un effet dissuasif rapide
et que vladimir poutine au final tremble
sur ses propres bases dans son propre
régime est-ce que sur le plan politique
l'europe est aujourd'hui armé pour faire
face aux défis sécuritaires que pose la
question où ceux qui craignaient nos
jour d'hui alors vous parlez d'une
europe armée elle est en tout cas là la
défense europe est de toute façon c'est
l'otan car il n'y a pas d'armée
européenne très clairement aujourd'hui
on a vu que l'europe avait
considérablement progressé sur la voie
de l'unité politique et ça c'est
important dès lors qu'elle a décidé à
l'unanimité malgré des hésitations au
début d' imposer de lourdes sanctions
financières et économiques à la russie
notamment sur la privation du bien des
oligarques l'exclusion du système
financier swift mais également dans la
capacité d'acheter des armements qui
doivent être et qui sont envoyées en ce
moment même en ukraine oui l'europe a
fait un pas politique de géant la
question est de savoir est ce que nous
resterons unis par la suite et cela de
toute façon ne suffira pas il faut
renforcer notre capacité stratégique les
défis sécuritaires auxquels les défis
économiques puisque on accomplit
également que les sanctions puisque le
toucher autant les cibles que ceux qui
les émettent
oui tout à fait vous savez que l'europe
est extrêmement dépendante d'un point de
vue énergétique nous allons souffrir
nous les consommateurs les citoyens
européens de cette crise économique
d'autant que les prix donc doubler les
prix de l'énergie vont augmenter
considérablement je pense que la russie
également va prendre des mesures de
rétorsion ne l'avions vu lors de la
crise de la crimée en 2014
donc nous allons en souffrir également
il faut malheureusement être prêt à
assumer ses conséquences des sanctions
économiques très lourdes imposées à la
russie merci beaucoup patrick martin
j'ai nié d'avoir été avec nous sur
france24 professeur à sciences po
spécialiste des questions européennes
côté diplomatie